عندما د.  وليد فتاح عاد إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية لم يتخيل أبدًا أنه
سينتهي به المطاف في السجن - تلقى تعليمه في جامعة هارفارد لأكثر
من عقد من الزمان في الممارسة الطبية في
الولايات المتحدة باعتباره جوهرة وطنية أمريكية سعودية ،
ربما شعر بالحماية قليلاً ولكن
ذلك لم يكن كذلك  في عام 2006 ، قامت عائلته
ببناء مستشفى في مدينة جدة المطلة على البحر
الأحمر.فتاح كان برأسين
وكان يعيد مهاراته إلى
جذوره ويساعده على علاج مرضه ،
وكان فخورًا بغرائز حقوق الإنسان التي اكتسبها
أكثر من 20  سنوات العيش في
الولايات المتحدة  فجأة في أواخر عام 2017 عندما قام
ولي العهد الشاب القوي في المملكة الصحراوية الأمير
محمد بن سلمان باعتقال كبار
الأمراء ورجل الأعمال متهمًا إياهم
بالفساد.فتاح وجد نفسه
عالقًا في شباك الجر الذي سُجن
مع آخرين في
فندق ريتز كارلتون بالرياض ، وتقول عائلته إنه كان كذلك.
تعرض للضرب والتعذيب ، ويقول محاميه
إنه نُقل إلى السجن دون اتباع
الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة ، وكتب إلى وزارة الخارجية في
يناير / كانون الثاني يطلب
المساعدة ، ويُعتقد أن د.  فتاح
تعرض للتعذيب النفسي على الأقل
خلال هذا السجن ،
لكن أجراس الإنذار دقت قبل ذلك بوقت طويل
في يناير من العام الماضي ،
الصحفي في واشنطن بوست جاماركوس يوشي ، غرد كيف
يمكن لشخص مثل الدكتور.  وليد فتاح
اعتقل وما هي أسباب
عدم بقاء كاكاشي على قيد الحياة للعثور على
الإجابات التي قُتل بوحشية من قبل
المسؤولين السعوديين الذين خلصت وكالة المخابرات المركزية إلى
أنهم كانوا يتصرفون بناءً على أوامر من بن سلمان
، ولا يزال ولي العهد الشاب يحظى
بتأييد الرئيس ترامب والأخير فقط
كان الأسبوع يتودد إليه من قبل مبعوثه إلى الشرق
الأوسط وصهره جاريد كوشنر جيويل لنا
فتح مواطن سعودي كان عليه الانتظار
أكثر من عام لجذب انتباه الجمهور ،
فقد حصلنا على ما يسمى
بالوصول إلى القنصلية مما يعني أن
الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين في المملكة العربية السعودية قد
زاروه بعد ذلك ، وليس
لدينا في الواقع أي معلومات إضافية في هذه
المرحلة لدى المسؤولين السعوديين  حتى الآن لم
يرد طلب CNN للتعليق أنهم
قالوا لصحيفة New York Times إنهم يأخذون
مزاعم سوء معاملة
المتهمين الذين ينتظرون المحاكمة والسجناء الذين
يقضون عقوباتهم على محمل الجد.